Dave what was the Tipping Point for you
to leave California I moved to LA in
2013. we had about a thousand bucks from
New York so I'm a true New Yorker born
in Brooklyn really the only two places
as an adult that I've lived until these
last three months were New York City and
LA and yet the ideas that I talk about
are the stuff that people care about in
the middle of the country I worked for
The Young Turks the two years of covid
demolished Los Angeles I could do all
the basic stuff the climb the homeless
is the drugs I campaigned with Larry
Elder for the for the recall and three
days after the recall do you want the
exact moment your mind is going to
explode three days after the recall I
got audited by the state I said we have
you ever been audited before I've never
been audited before my stuff's all
cleaned it was all fine we take very
good care of all my businesses
immediately like literally I think I
hung up the phone and I called my real
estate agent I said get me out of here I
am so happy to be here and I'm really
like as I said I'm born here I feel you
feel it here in Florida